[Rires]
[Musique]
coupe ils disent c'est une idée là c'est
unique dans le sud de l'australie qui
attire des gens de partout à travers le
monde
il ya environ 2500 habitants ici 40
nationalités différentes et ça s'est
passé en 1915 il ya un adolescent que
découvert de l'opal par hasard ici et
tout de suite après des mineurs se sont
rués vers coupe au pilier pour creuser
[Musique]
georges par exemple est d'origine
grecque l'a abandonné une grande
carrière en publicité dans l'espoir de
devenir millionnaire en trouvant de
l'opep si tu déterminer ce qu'ils
cherchent c'est une pierre fine contre
surtout en australie mais aussi dans des
pays comme le brésil et l'ethiopie pour
que le palais de la valeur il faut
qu'elle soit brillante et surtout
qu'elles reflètent certaines couleurs
[Musique]
mais parfois il peut piocher pendant des
semaines avant de récolter quoi que ce
soit
dans les années 70 et 80 il y avait des
milliers de mineurs a couvert pilée
[Musique]
aujourd'hui il n'en reste que quelques
dizaines ils ne veulent pas montré à la
caméra
où exactement on peut trouver de l'eau
parce que n'importe qui pourrait venir
la nuit ont volé leurs pierres 9h09
les gens ici pour pas juste creuser pour
trouver la balle ils ont aussi creusé
leur maison en fait il avait dans les
trous mais c'est plus confortablement en
fait le seul à courir puis est parsemée
de collines de but naturelle à
l'intérieur desquelles des habitants
s'installent pour se protéger de la
chaleur
ok on a rendez vous avec un couple qui
va nous faire découvrir les maisons
typiques de la région
la première maison cindy est un doux
nous montre est inhabitée mais elle
illustre bien à quoi pouvait ressembler
la vie à l'époque du beau milieu sous
l'immeuble a abandonné on découvre les
trappes et des couloirs qui n'en
finissent jamais bien des propriétaires
chercher de la paille dans leur propre
maison
l'idée de vivre sous terre est
d'ailleurs venue des mineurs eux-mêmes
qui au départ dormait souvent dans leur
trou aujourd'hui les maisons
souterraines sont très confortables
il fait toujours de 23 à 25 degrés sans
art climatisés même si le mercure
dépasse parfois les 45 degrés celsius
[Musique]
vendredi soir 21h he jun nous a proposé
d'aller chercher de l'opal décidé de se
lancer
[Musique]
franchement avec des lumière
ultraviolette c'est plus facile d'en
apercevoir que durant deux jours on a
fait quelques trouvailles
mais quand on les montre à georges dans
sa bijouterie son verdict est sans appel
soit fourni sans pitié
clairement on n'est pas prêts pour un
changement de carrière à coup boufigue
il ya ceux qui peuvent vivre dans les
trous est ce que tu peux lui faire
fortune